good evening I'm Matthew Spalding I'm
the associate vice president and Dean
for Hillsdale College here in Washington
DC as you know Hillsdale College isn't
it's an old college and it's not in DC
but this is our Washington DC campus and
I invite welcome you to it where we
extend our teaching mission about
liberal arts but also the principles and
institutions of American government we
have undergraduates programs a
fellowship program for young
professionals and very soon of all those
well a graduate school here in
Washington DC to teach these ideas in
short to teach people what it need what
they need to know to be a statesman one
of the things we're very interested in
teaching on our main campus and here are
the arts of Liberty as we call them the
things one needs to know to maintain
Liberty which depend on a constitution
and its structure as Madison would
emphasize and the Federalist Papers
things like the separation of powers but
also this other institutional structure
called the electoral college and I'm
very happy to say we have an excellent
an expert on the question and a good
friend of mine who's also engaged in the
current debate Trent England is the
executive vice president at the Oklahoma
Council of public affairs where he's
also the David and Anne Brown
Distinguished Fellow and directs the
save our state's project he's an adjunct
fellow of New Mexico's Rio Grande
Foundation and he hosts a podcast he's
actually a previously a radio did
morning radio but he has a podcast
called a Trent England show he really
served as the executive vice president
of the Freedom Foundation and it was a
legal policy analyst Heritage Foundation
he was also a candidate for Washington
State House of Representatives their
loss because he's with us today he's
written for numerous publications
including The Wall Street Journal
Christian Science Monitor The Washington
Times he's contributed to an excellent
excellent publication well edited called
the Harwich guide to the Constitution
and he also contributed one nation under
arrest how crazy laws rogue prosecutors
in Access
just threaten our liquor your liberty
here in his JD from George Mason
University's School of Law and his BA in
government from Claremont McKenna
College where I'm very sad to say makes
me feel old it makes him young where he
was my student yo those many years ago
and despite that he's gone on to be a
fine scholar so I give you transient
[Applause]
thank you all so much thank you thank
you Matt it's a just a pleasure to be
here and be introduced by you and and
I'd be remiss if I didn't also say thank
you to - Doug Jeffery from from
Hillsdale and also of course president
Larry Arne and and just to say something
before I get into my remarks about about
the importance of what they do here I
was thinking as I as I was preparing all
of this I was I was thinking about when
I got interested in the electoral
college as a topic of study and it was
before the electoral college was cool
before 2000 because of the the story one
professor at Claremont McKenna College
told about another professor the
professor was Michael yulman telling a
story about Martin diamond who just down
the street from here testified in 1977
before a Senate committee that was it
was hearing a proposal to abolish the
Electoral College and at the end of that
hearing he stood up and he began to want
to walk out and he fell over in died of
a heart attack and it's just stuck in my
mind is this young kid is this image it
was the one image I had of this valiant
scholar of politics in our
constitutional regime who sort of died
with his boots on I thought I would I
happy to survive but but I want to be
that kind of scholar
right and and it left me with this this
interest in the electoral college that
that has lived on oh these many many
years so so let me let me tell you the
story of the electoral college once upon
a time the electoral college was not
controversial in the ratification
debates the anti-federalists critics of
the Constitution barely brought it up
barely had anything to say about the the
electoral college yet by the 20th
century opponents had nearly convinced
Congress two different times once in
1977 once earlier in the 50s largely
stopped by John F Kennedy bipartisan
critics of the electoral college almost
convinced Congress to to pass out an
amendment to abolish this whole system
what happened and does it even matter
critics of the electoral college point
out they're merely trying to get
president elected the way we elect
pretty much everybody else who's elected
in our country governors are all elected
by a statewide popular vote so why not a
national popular vote for president in
1787 the framers of the Constitution
asked themselves the same question they
considered and rejected a national
popular vote along with several other
possible modes of election the Virginia
Plan the first draft of what would
become the new constitution called for a
national an executive to be chosen by
the national legislature when the when
the Constitutional Convention took up
this issue for the first time about a
week into their debates near
Pennsylvania's James Wilson called for a
popular election and Roger Sherman from
Connecticut jumped up to support the
Virginia plans parliamentary system
arguing that the executive should be
quote absolutely dependent on the
legislature Virginia's George Mason
responded that a popular election was
impracticable but he hoped that Wilson
would quote have time to giant digest
the plan into his own form another
delegate said that the Senate should
have that power and then the convention
adjourned for the day and when they came
back the next day on Saturday morning it
turned out that Wilson had taken Mason's
advice he presented a plan to create
districts and hold popular elections to
choose electors and those electors would
then go on to vote for the executive in
other words Wilson proposed an electoral
college so early in the in the
constitutional convention but with many
details left out and the whole the whole
nature of the executive undecided right
the whole question of whether we would
have one president or a council or I
mean all this was up in the air Wilson's
proposal was voted down a week later
Massachusetts delegate Albert Elbridge
Gerry proposed election by state
governors this too was voted down but a
theme begins to appear delegates did not
defend the Virginia plans parliamentary
model so much as they criticized the
other plans that were brought up as
having some of the same flaws or or
other flaws
themselves yes an executive elected by
Congress might be subservient to that
body but a similar similar result could
be expected from giving that power to
any other body of elected officials in
July there was a proposal I like this
one there was a proposal to draw lots in
Congress to select electors and then and
then all those whichever members of
Congress drew out the the the right
colored balls out of the the jar they
actually talked some of this through
they would be ushered off into a private
room the doors would be closed and
they'd have to decide on a president
before they could come out in in secret
right and this was this is again trying
to surmount the problems it with that
that were inherent in the Virginia Plan
another idea was that the the
legislature the National Legislature
would appoint the executive but only
States through some kind of electoral
appointment process could could
reappoint the president right again
trying to get around this this idea of
the president being subservient to
Congress all of these oddball efforts
show that that the Virginia plans idea
was failing and had failed and James
Madison summed it up on July 25th when
he said quote the option before us is
between an appointment by electors
chosen by the people and an immediate
appointment by the people and Madison
said that he preferred election by the
people but he pointed out two problems
first people would likely prefer
candidates from their own state and that
would benefit the biggest States to the
detriment of the smaller states second
and related to that a few areas with
high concentrations of voters could
dominate everybody else madison spoke on
the other hand only positively of the
idea of some kind of electoral college
finding that quote there would be very
little opportunity for cabal or
corruption in such a system
others echoed Madison's concerns and
raised additional objections of their
own Gary said a popular election would
be radically vicious because it would in
effect hand over to organizations
capable of manipulating public opinion
the selection of the president another
delegate predicted that a national
election would become complex
and unwieldy by the end of August the
Constitution was almost done just a few
issues remained and the biggest of those
was this question how do we elect the
President of the United States a
committee was it was selected one
delegate from each state present so they
called the committee of eleven it
included James Madison and they were
given this task on August 31st going in
figure this out they brought back a plan
on September 4th and it was adopted the
next day with minor changes and it is
the Electoral College as it is written
in article 2 of the Constitution this is
this is what it says each state shall
appoint in such manner as the
legislature there have might may direct
a number of electors equal to the whole
number of Senators and Representatives
to which the state may be entitled in
Congress it goes on in article 2 section
1 to prohibit federal officials from
being electors actually came up once
Oregon had an Electra disqualified for
that reason in 1888 or in 1876 to
require electors to cast two ballots and
to prohibit them from casting both
ballots for candidates from their own
state a deadlock for president is
decided by the house and in casting one
vote per state a deadlock for
vice-president is decided by the Senate
the runner-up under the original system
became vice president this last
provision made Jane made John Adams
miserable I mean absolutely miserable
when his arch nemesis Thomas Jefferson
became his vice president in after the
1796 election and then of course it
almost robbed Thomas Jefferson to the
presidency when his unscrupulous running
mate Aaron Burr tried to manipulate an
unintended deadlock in the electoral
college to result in his own election as
president for the House course that
didn't didn't work out for Aaron Burr
and and ultimately didn't work out very
well for Alexander Hamilton who brokered
the election of Jefferson over burr the
twelfth amendment which was ratified in
1804 fixed all of this by requiring
electors to cast separate votes one for
president and one
vice president and their things stand
constitutionally at least the
state-by-state presidential election
process has remained the same for 205
years
now state legislatures use their power
to direct the manner of choosing
electors in various ways appointing them
directly holding elections by district
or most of the time electing them all in
a statewide popular vote winner-take-all
most legislators have determined and in
mathematically it's correct that that
system maximizes the power of a state in
presidential elections one statewide
winner-take-all
vote Maine and Nebraska of course do it
differently in Maine and Nebraska they
elect one elector from each
congressional district and then the
remaining two who represent the the
Senators in that tally in the statewide
vote the way everybody else does of
course it's easy for American voters to
forget that when we vote for president
we're really voting for electors civics
education is not what it used to be and
perhaps the electoral colleges in a way
really a victim of its own success most
of the time the Electoral College shapes
our politics in ways that are beneficial
but very hard to see when its effects do
jump out in the open that is only
because some candidate in his or her
political party has just lost a
hard-fought and narrowly decided
election all of a sudden we remember
that we have this Electoral College and
some people wonder why we do but what
are the beneficial effects that that are
that are sometimes so hard to see what
are the beneficial effects of the
electoral college or to put it another
way if James Madison was here today so
one of the reasons I like this question
I me sometimes as conservatives I think
we can lapse into saying well James
Madison said it should be this way so we
should do it this way but I think the
more important question is if Madison
was here with us today right he wouldn't
want to know what he said 205 or 215
years ago he would want to know what's
happened over these last 200 plus years
what would what would Madison say what
would Madison think one obvious result
of the Electoral College is a practical
respect for states both their boundaries
and their legislators in presidential
elections well the federal government
has assumed many
powers ones left to the states election
administration remains primarily a state
function the current system contains
presidential elections within state
lines allowing elections to remain
relatively decentralized of course some
see this is a flaw senator Elizabeth
Warren recently called for abolishing
the Electoral College and link this to
her support for more federal power over
elections at a CNN Town Hall in in March
Warren called for a constitutional
amendment to replace the electoral
college with what she called national
voting and this is this is one one of
the reasons actually why the
organization that I used to be with the
Freedom Foundation in Washington State
took this issue on to begin with we did
a lot of work on election integrity some
of you may remember the Dino Rossi
governor's election in Washington State
in 2004 and and we recognize that that
pretty much all of the groups behind
national popular vote this effort I'm
going to talk about in just a minute
saw it as a part of a strategy a part of
a vision to centralize power over
elections to take the power away from
the states and put it here in Washington
DC the Electoral College has prevented
that and even its critics recognize this
but containing elections within state
within state lines has other benefits as
well the Electoral College turn state
boundaries into something like the the
watertight compartments on an ocean
liner disputes over mistakes or fraud
real fraud imagine fraud whatever kind
of fraud are contained within individual
states rather than spilling over into a
need for nationwide recounts or again
greater federal control this was
important in America's messiest
presidential election which was not 2000
but was 1876 in in my opinion at least
this was the first time a candidate won
any electoral vote majority while
another candidate received more popular
votes nationwide some people say that
was 1824 but that's not correct because
in 1824 six states appointed electors
directly and didn't hold a vote in their
state there was no national popular vote
in 1824 but there was in 1876
and this was during a
of time during the rise of voter
suppression and a tremendous amount of
election fraud in the South tiny margins
and obvious fraud in this light and
there was fraud on both sides in this
election but but obvious fraud in this
election led to disputes over the totals
in Florida Louisiana and South Carolina
these states literally sent to Congress
competing slates of electors they sent
the they sent the Democrats sent their
electors the Republicans sent their
electors to Congress and Congress had to
figure this out
two days before inauguration day I mean
again this is this is got to be the
messiest presidential election two days
before inauguration day Congress finally
finished counting the votes determining
to count the the Republican votes in
favor of Ruth referred Behe's rather
than the Democrat votes for Samuel
Tilden Democrats proclaimed this the
fraud of the century but there's simply
no way to tell what the what the correct
result was in this election there was no
way to tell probably at the time it is
clear that racist voter suppression
would become an important part of
Democrats hold on political power in the
contested states and at the very least
and I I agree with with his with the
historians who come to the conclusion
that it's likely that the Electoral
College prevented that racist vote
suppression from stealing a presidential
election although again nobody can prove
that you had there's some extrapolation
that you have to go through to get to
that result but but at the very least
the Electoral College contained those
disputes within individual states so
that Congress could sort them out the
next election in 1880 shows another
effect of the electoral college system
and often amplifies the result and
enhances the credibility of a new
president the popular vote margin in
1880 was less than 10,000 votes so this
is about a point one percent margin
right sometimes people who support a
national popular vote system say well
just you didn't ever have a close close
election if his nationwide you had too
many votes for that in 1880 is Exhibit A
for why that's not correct neither
candidate in 1880 had a popular vote
majority which is the case in most close
elections
James Garfield however won a resounding
victory
with 214 electoral votes to win filled
Hancock's 155 there was no question who
won the electoral college often has this
effect it bolsters the legitimacy of
plurality winners this was true in 1992
when Bill Clinton won just 43 percent of
the popular vote but over 68 percent of
the electoral vote and you know this
this is a good thing right I mean I
think it's easy to see that a narrow
plurality is is inferior to a broad
plurality right it's better going to
have a plurality winner it's better that
that plurality winner is drawing support
from a wide swath of the country rather
than a narrow region or a few major
cities perhaps the greatest benefit of
our state by state election process
however is the powerful incentive it
creates against regionalism and this is
this is always true this always informs
how presidential campaigns are put
together but it's easiest to see in the
late 19th century again in 1888
incumbent President Grover Cleveland
lost re-election despite receiving an
electoral votes ease me a popular vote
plurality this happened because he won
big in the south Cleveland's national
popular vote margin was ninety four
thousand five hundred and thirty but he
won Texas by one hundred and forty six
thousand four hundred and sixty-one
votes in other words some of you were
making this connection right Texas for
Grover Cleveland was in in 1888 was
California for Hillary Clinton in 2016
right one state intense support in one
state was responsible for a hundred and
fifty percent of his popular vote margin
he had altogether he had won six states
Cleveland won six states with greater
than thirty percent while while only
tiny Vermont delivered with such zeal
for Republican Benjamin Harrison in
other words the Republican votes were
drawn from a broader area with less
intense regional support and it's just
fun to think about Vermont being that
you know that the hotbed of Republican
sentiment they were they were feeling
the Bern I guess the the election this
election showed that radical support in
one
the country was not enough to win the
White House but Democrats already knew
this after the Civil War and especially
after the end of Reconstruction the
strength of the Democratic Party was in
the South you might think it might it
would make sense that they would be
nominating candidates from the south
that's where most of the the Democrats
were that's where most of their support
was instead the Democrats nominated know
southerners for president or vice
president between 1872 and 1928 if you
exclude West Virginia which of course he
should because West Virginia only exists
because it stayed with the north during
the Civil War
yet nobody right from 1872 to 1928 they
were doing everything they could to
reach out into the north and Grover
Cleveland and his running mate both both
northerners just like Al Gore in 2000 if
Grover Cleveland had just won his own
home state of New York he would have
become president winning the presidency
requires something more than a raw
popular vote plurality it requires in
winning enough states to earn a majority
of electoral college votes Grover
Cleveland did this he came back in 1892
to become president again it's why he's
you know he's a common jeopardy answer
right he's the only only person to serve
two non-consecutive terms as president
he actually received the smaller
plurality in 1892 because the populist
party got 8.5 percent of the national
popular vote but Cleveland won a
resounding electoral college victory
because he won his home state of New
York he won his running mates home state
of Illinois he also won Indiana
Wisconsin and California he broadened
his coalition and won the electoral
college and so it goes whether we see it
or not the electoral college pushes
parties and their presidential campaigns
to build broad coalition's and then to
focus on the most closely divided States
this has become a popular attack on the
system swing states get a lot of
attention and other voters feel left out
yet more Americans live today in highly
partisan safe congressional districts
than in quote/unquote safe states right
if you don't like save States you should
be really upset about congressional
districts far more by my calculations
about twice as many America
live in safe congressional districts if
people's votes are being ignored or left
out or not counted or something it's a
much bigger problem in the US House and
it is with the Electoral College but the
very legitimacy of a political party
really rests on those safe states right
a political party a national political
party has to have a broad base of strong
support across the country you have to
have enough safe states that you can
then credibly reach out in swing states
to actually have an opportunity to win
the White House in 2000 people forget
you know people say in 2000 George W
Bush you know the only state that
mattered was Florida if Georgia people
should lost any state that he won in
2000 he would not have become president
right again if Al Gore had won his home
state Al Gore would have become
president right every single state
mattered every state matters every vote
within a state matters at least as much
as in elections for governor or senator
which are sometimes very close and other
times foregone conclusions this comes up
I go to hearings on the Electoral
College in states all around the country
and I was in in Nevada for hearing a
couple a week ago and and this came up
there was all this confusion between a
state senator and the the lobbyist who
was there against the electoral college
on which votes don't matter right it is
your vote not matter if you're in a if
you're in a swing state but you vote for
the loser or if you're in a safe state
and you vote for the winner and and and
they just talked round and round around
and I got a good chuckle of it cuz it's
confusing because it makes no sense
right I mean I mean many of us at least
have lived in swing states and safe
States and swing congressional districts
and safe congressional districts and the
same with state legislative races and
city council races and the idea that
that how I feel about my vote or or how
my vote matters is determined by the the
margin in in the in the election just
doesn't really make a lot of sense I
think when you when you tease that out
the Electoral College does of course put
a premium on states that happen to be
the most balanced in a particular
election but the flip side is will we
really rather the path to the presidency
run through the the the most that the
reddest of the red states and the bluest
of the blue states right or would we
rather it run through the states that
happen to be the most evenly balanced
consider one more quality of swing
states they are also the most likely to
have both parties represented in
government to have divided government if
divided government is good for one thing
it's good for accountability in other
words the way the Electoral College
works out when we do wind up with a
razor-thin margin at least it's it's
likely to happen in a state where both
parties have some power rather than in a
state where one party controls
everything despite all these benefits
detractors maintain that it's simply
unseemly for a candidate to win without
receiving the most popular votes Hillary
Clinton said in 2000 that in a democracy
we should respect the will of the people
and to me that means it's time to do
away with the Electoral College yet
similar systems prevail around the world
I didn't used to point this out but I've
realized I was in a hearing in Maine at
the beginning of the year and somebody
said well if we just abolish the
Electoral College we would have we would
have higher voter turnout like they have
in Canada and I thought to myself maybe
these people really don't realize what a
parliamentary system is right I mean
people everyone assumes that Canada the
United Kingdom Australia India is
oftentimes talked about as the largest
democracy in the world everybody assumes
all these countries are democracies and
I've discovered that some people assume
that that means that they vote directly
for their executive but of course that's
not true in any of those countries
right they have parliamentary systems
they elect our prime ministers in a
two-step process that is arguably less
democratic I think it's clearly less
democratic than our electoral college
system is right I mean Theresa May did
not get elected based on anything like
the national popular vote I mean nobody
even nobody even you cast a vote for her
in even a two-step process right they
cast a vote for the Conservative Party
for their Member of Parliament Indian
Germany actually also have Germany has a
chancellor India has a president and in
addition to their parliamentary systems
and their prime ministers they actually
have something very similar to an
electoral college India calls it an
electoral college again the largest
democracy in the world
designed to do exactly everything that
we've talked about here to balance out
geographical interest to prevent
regional radicalism from tearing the
country apart in in by the way the other
on the other side the countries that
come to mind when you think of a
national popular vote Russia and France
and if you've followed Russian and
French elections over the last twenty or
thirty years you will know that they
have not been uniformly happy with the
outcomes of their elections for a
variety of reasons most recently in
France where the first round of their
election McCrone gets twenty four
percent and lepen gets I think twenty
one percent right and you know most of
the proposals to get rid of the
electoral college would leave it right
there right twenty four percent you win
France has a second round they have a
runoff system you know how many French
voters were unhappy with that result
with having the choice between a 24%
candidate and a 21% candidate so many
French voters were unhappy with that
that they they didn't just stay home
they went to the polls and 600,000
French voters cast a blank ballot in
protest at their national popular vote
democratic system right and of course
right here at home
what matters most in every legislative
body from the Oklahoma House of
Representatives to the United States
Senate is which party is in control that
party elects leadership and sets the
agenda and in neither chamber of
Congress nor in any of the 99 state
legislative chambers does the national
popular vote matter at all what matters
is winning districts or winning States
and I mentioned the hearing in Nevada I
just have to say this because it was a
high point of my year there were two
people from the National Education
Association at the hearing to testify
against the electoral college it's
undemocratic our students don't like it
we you should get rid of the electoral
college and and I I thought I think I
know how the NEA elects its president
and I you know I looked it up on my
phone and when I testified I was able to
share with the committee that of course
the NEA elects their president through
basically an electoral college system
their constituent assembly so
a lot of people don't realize that you
know this electoral college system isn't
quite the the you know out-of-left-field
anomaly that people portray it as
nevertheless we hear the clamor of
voices calling for an end to the
electoral college some of this is just
sour grapes and posturing opposing this
part of the Constitution has become an
emblem of the resistance and it fits
neatly within the progressive idea that
whatever might help them obtain power
must be progress Hillary Clinton said
recently that we have evolved beyond the
electoral college former attorney
General Eric Holder declared it a
vestige of the past in Washington
governor jay Inslee identified it as one
of several archaic relics of a bygone
age Democratic presidential hopefuls
from Beta o'rourke to Elizabeth Warren
have jumped at opportunities to call for
abolishing the Electoral College over
the last couple of months
in fact what some of these Democrats
might realize or their advisors perhaps
is that is how similar their party's
position in the 21st century is to what
it was in the late 19th century
California is becoming for the
Democratic Party of today what the South
was for their forerunners the Golden
State accounted for ten point four
percent of the votes cast in 2016 while
the southern states from South Carolina
to Florida and over to Texas you kind of
draw that triangle in your mind those
southern states accounted for ten point
six percent of the votes cast in 1888
Cleveland won those southern states by
nearly 39% Hillary Clinton won
California by 30 percent so not quite
the same intensity but close in other
words rather than building a broader
coalition required by the electoral
college some modern-day Democrats would
rather change the rules to increase the
chances that their current narrower
coalition can win the White House
whether for posturing or politics calls
to amend the Constitution or a
dime-a-dozen
even anti electoral college amendments
with broad bipartisan support in the 50s
and the 70s failed to receive the
required two-thirds support to be sent
to the states for consideration partisan
amendments are not going to make it
through Congress any time soon nor will
they win ratification from the states
there is however a serious
threat to the electoral college until
recently it has gone mostly unnoticed as
it has made its way through various
state legislatures if it works according
to its supporters intent it would
nullify the electoral college and wipe
away all the benefits by creating a de
facto direct election for president how
is this possible without changing the
Constitution the national popular vote
interstate compact or NPV takes
advantage of the flexibility granted to
state legislatures in the Constitution
remember each state shall appoint in
such manner as the legislature thereof
may direct a number of electors the
original intent here is clear of course
it's to allow legislators to determine
how best to represent their own state in
presidential elections the electors
represent the state not just the
legislature even though the latter has
power to direct their own states to
direct the manner of appointment NPV
would have states ignore how their own
people vote and give away all of their
state's electors to whichever candidate
that state believes won the national
popular vote
excuse me of course no state would do
this unilaterally so NPV has a trigger
it only takes effect if adopted by
enough states that they control together
270 electoral votes in other words a
majority that would control the outcome
of presidential elections so far 14
states worth 200 and excuse me 189
electoral votes have adopted the
national popular vote interstate compact
until this year every state that had
joined was deep blue California
Connecticut Hawaii Illinois Maryland
Massachusetts New Jersey New York Rhode
Island Vermont and Washington the nvv
campaign has struggled to win a few blue
states Delaware only adopted it this
year still has not passed in Oregon
excuse me although it although it may
pass there soon
following the 2018 election Democrats
new trifectas in purple Colorado and in
purple New Mexico wasted no time joining
NPV but others have not Democrat
legislators actually helped
kill the major this session in Maine and
New Hampshire and some seem unsold
at this time in Nevada if NPV ever did
take effect it would have all the same
effects as abolishing the electoral
college outright fraud in one state
would affect every other state and the
only way to deal with it would be to
give more power to the federal
government an especially close election
would require a nationwide recount
candidates could win based on intense
support from one region of the country
or a small collection of big cities
MTV's jury rigged direct election system
also brings some unique risks despite
its name the plan cannot actually create
a national popular vote national popular
vote interstate compact does not create
a national popular vote states would
still for the time being run their own
elections this would mean a patchwork of
rules for everything from which
candidates get on the ballot and in
particular states to how disputes are
sorted out and it would reward states
for having lacks election laws just
imagine with me two states side-by-side
everything about those states is
identical but one state has laws saying
you should show but you should show
photo ID to register to vote in the cast
your ballot and you know I mean we're
gonna have have we're gonna try to have
strict controls for election integrity
in the state next-door says we're gonna
allow felons to vote from prison as
Bernie Sanders suggested the other day
that the state with the lacks election
rules would benefit right would have
more political power under national
popular vote in the state with stricter
election controls I don't think that
goes unnoticed by the the advocates here
finally each npv state would certify the
national total for its own on its own
right and the question here is is is
interesting right because the npv
compact essentially not very long it
reads very simple and it is it is
portrayed as if the the benefit of is
it's very simple it just doesn't mention
a lot of things like how you would
decide to dispute but think about this
every state within the compact would
certify the the national popular vote
election result for itself well so what
what happens in in a hard-fought
election when California
voters are watching on MSNBC and being
told that the margin of victory for the
Republican candidate is only because of
voter suppression in some southern red
state or flip it around right Republican
voters in Texas are watching Fox News
and they're watching scenes from Chicago
and being told that the Democrats have a
you know that they're they're ahead by a
narrow margin and it's only because of a
ballot box stuffing in Chicago right
what are those state officials who
supposedly are gonna certify an election
total based on what other states tell
them all trust no verify no power to
determine the veracity of what any other
state says and all these officials are
elected officials they're politicians
most of them are people who want to
become either governor or senator in
their state that's who secretaries the
state typically are right or are they
going to how are they going to respond
when they start getting phone calls from
donors saying I just saw this on MSNBC
or I just saw this on Fox News
don't you dare certify a national
election total that includes
California's votes or Texas's votes or
whatever right and then there's I mean
there's just literally no way to sort
this out under the npv compact the only
certain result of the national popular
vote compact would be uncertainty
including litigation the mtv compact is
at least constitutionally dubious
although it is not sometimes I have
conservatives tell me I don't worry
about this because it's clearly
unconstitutional it is it is
constitutionally dubious it does
something nobody's ever trying to do
before I mean for one thing it does
ignore the requirement in the
Constitution that interstate compacts
receive congressional consent but npv
lobbyists point out no no court has ever
enforced that that constitutional
provision to strike down and there's the
interstate compact would they do it in
this case maybe judges might also hold
that the structure of the Constitution's
electoral college clause does imply some
outer limit to the power of state
legislatures to ignore the will of their
own people this came up in a hearing
earlier this year where a a committee
attorney in in the Nevada Legislature
again was in
seeing that national popular vote is is
legal it's constitutional but he did say
he said but you know we're not arguing
that the legislature could do anything
we're not arguing that the legislature
could sell their electoral votes and
what's interesting I kind of looked over
at the national popular vote lobbyists
and I've been following these guys
around for 10 years and so I know who
they are and I and I kind of watched
them squirm because their argument is
that no the legislature could do
whatever it wants right there's nothing
in the Constitution that says you can't
sell your electoral votes just like
there's nothing in the Constitution on
its face that says that you can't rob
your state's people of their electoral
votes and give them away based on how
people vote in New York and Los Angeles
right the question is does the original
purpose of the electoral college control
or not and again I I don't put enough
faith in judges to say that I'm not
gonna worry about it based on that but I
do think there's a live question there
however uncertainty might be part of the
objective or at least might play into
the hands of electoral college and
opponents if you know the history of the
17th amendment part of how we got the
17th amendment which took away the power
from state legislatures to appoint their
state there their US senators was
because opponents to the existing system
created a tremendous amount of
uncertainty and unease around that
system and eventually Congress did what
they had refused to do up to that point
was was assure out this is what became
the 17th amendment for direct election
of senators well one danger of course to
all these attacks on the electoral
colleges is that they succeed one
dangers that they succeed that we lose
the state-by-state system designed by
the framers and thus lose the
protections against regionalism and
fraud and the recognition of States as
States in our constitutional system this
would alter our political ecosystem and
some obvious ways shifting power towards
urban centers for example but also in
ways we cannot be sure of small
plurality winners would be more likely
would that lead to a rise in splinter
parties or or spoiler candidates would
conservative fears of election fraud in
places like Chicago lead to a demand
from the right for greater federal
control over elections and I really I
really think in in a direct election
world I
it would be conservatives who would
demand that the federal government take
more power over elections because of
concerns about election fraud and in in
that case right I mean conservatives
would if I'm right conservators would
get that what they want because that's
been an agenda item for the left for a
long time the danger however is not
merely that the attacks succeed in
eliminating or neutering the electoral
college the more fundamental risk is
that the public adheres to the beliefs
that underlie these attacks but the
Constitution is out of date that the
measure of an election is voter
self-esteem and that democracy is an end
in itself all of these beliefs can has
easily be turned against any of our
constitutional checks and balances the
measure of our fundamental law is not
whether it actualizes the general will
that was the French Revolution on our
Revolution the measure of our
Constitution is whether it tends towards
justice and things that support justice
including stability the Electoral
College does this and we ought not only
to preserve it but also to help our
fellow Americans understand why it
matters thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm happy to take questions until okay
well thank you so much for speaking
about this incredibly important subject
many questions which I'll save for after
but one in particular is and I'm came a
little late so maybe you touched on this
very early on but there is the proposal
that many Republicans have been in favor
of over the years of breaking estates
electoral votes down by a congressional
district what Nebraska and Maine already
do without any legal opposition so it's
presumably is legal with the to Senator
bonus as it were to whoever wins the
state overall what is your sense this
that it's a state should be integral on
to the whole and how it votes or would a
breakdown by congressional vote maybe
make people in certain states feel more
satisfied while preserving the system so
as a general rule in any in any state
that tends to go one direction for
president the people on the other side
want that system I used to live in
Washington State and and that was always
something that would come up why can't
we break up our electoral votes of
course it doesn't happen because washing
is a Democrat leaning state the
Democrats control the state they benefit
from from a winner-take-all system
because it does maximize the impact of
this state as a state I mean as a
general rule right I think this this
flexibility in article two where
legislators can figure out how to
represent their state I think it's a
good thing but I think I think also as a
general rule the Maine and Nebraska
system is Manabi as' problem that you
bring gerrymandering into presidential
elections and that's why I mean III I
did these this calculation a few years
ago I was just just curious I had a
hunch but I I wanted to see how many
Americans live in safe States versus
safe congressional districts and as I
mentioned I mean it's it's twice as many
because of gerrymandering twice as many
Americans live in non-competitive by my
calculation it's sort of subjective but
I used a five percent threshold
so I think I think that's that's an
issue and I also I also think that I
have had a problem with Republicans who
have talked about it very explicitly as
a way to game the system Democrats
actually tried to do that in in Colorado
in 2006 put a measure on the ballot to
do it and voters voted it down because
they kind of figured out that it was
Democrats being opportunistic and that
was 2006 right Democrats thought we're
never gonna win call around with
statewide but at least we should get 45%
of its electoral votes in 2008 they won
Colorado so I think there's a big danger
from for partisans trying to be you know
too clever by now sir yeah I'm just yeah
I'm just making sure you get the mic um
my questions a little outside the box
but I don't understand what exactly they
intended by an elector and in other
words my impression without knowing a
lot was oh that way they would vote
everybody would vote for electors who
would be people who would be intelligent
honest competent and it wouldn't be this
sort of political vote it would just be
let's get some some people to study the
issues and I kind of think on a national
level voting is kind of a crazy thing
because people can't possibly understand
these issues you know I read about them
all day long and I don't really think
I'm the competent person to understand
you know all these issues and the
implication throughout the entire
country so I think it would be a good
idea to have an elector whose job it is
is to study these things and I that's
what I thought an elector was but
correct me about why I'm Maya I have a
misconception well no you don't have a
misconception at all I mean it's it's
really it's it's related to the reason
why I mentioned I one of the reasons I
think I mentioned I like this issue I
mean this is an issue where partly
because the the the framers settled on
it's so late in the convention Ian
because the anti-federalists were okay
with it there's not we know that some of
them thaw
that states were just going to appointed
lecturers the electors would get
together they would they would cast
votes for president if there was an
obvious choice like George Washington
that person would be elected if there
wasn't an obvious choice probably but
people would vote for a favorite son
candidate and then maybe because they
cast two votes and one had to be for
somebody from another state maybe you'd
still wind up with a you know George
Washington almost somebody who had that
level of prominence or it would deadlock
and I think I think there's you know
there is some evidence that a lot of
thought know the house is gonna wind up
doing this most of the time cuz nobody's
gonna get a majority in the electoral
college but as soon as the system was in
place and George Washington wasn't there
anymore
the the framers themselves the people
who designed this system basically
started using it in a partisan way the
way that we use it today started having
elections it was the Jeffersonians who
came up with the winner-take-all system
because they were upset that that
Virginia wasn't going all for them and I
think it's I think it's it's one of
those areas where the kind of the the
full weight of the founders intellect
was never brought to bear to do a really
rigorous you know how is human nature
going to interact with this
constitutional structure and they wind
up discovering for themselves through
their own human nature you know how it
actually works but no I I mean I I think
I mean yeah they thought they thought
that they would get together in their
own in their own states and and
deliberate I mean that's at least at
least some of them thought that that was
what was what was going to happen I mean
as really as you described but the
record is the record is thin right so we
don't we don't know that they all
thought that but we know some of them
thought that and of course it did it
worked out that way for George
Washington but but everybody knew was
gonna be George Washington anyway right
and I do think you know one of our
problems that is just outside of this
whole question the Electoral College is
the the aggrandizement of the executive
the president and and I don't think that
it's one of the reasons I worry about a
national popular vote system I mean it
that that further aggrandized as the
negative and that is actually an
argument that some some Democrats in the
Trump era recognize and some Democrats
back in the George W Bush era when they
were all upset about the Iraq war and
what they thought were abused as a
presidential power back then there were
some Democrats opposed to national
popular vote for that very reason they
said we don't we don't want presidents
claiming to have a clear popular mandate
because we think it'll make them even
even more you know feel even more
freedom to steamroll Congress this may
also be a little off the mark but there
are some states now run by Democrats who
are trying to put a requirement on their
people who can run for president in
their state - in this case provide their
tax returns
now that's strictly local politics but
let's say that states tried to put more
of the requirements on presidential
candidates than are in the Constitution
which sets up who can run I'm pulling a
bad example out of my back pocket
my state will now not allow anybody to
run for president who doesn't pledge to
never take military action against North
Korea Pakistan Iraq a litany of a pledge
to do something in my case foreign
policy what would you know what do you
think of that and how do we prevent that
yeah I'm glad you brought that up
because then yeah that has been going on
in a number of states I think some
states have action I think of actually
it's actually been enacted I believe
this session and yeah what they're doing
it's ballot access law you know you
can't be on their ballot as a
presidential candidate unless you unless
you've released a certain number of your
years of tax returns
of course functionally these are these
are really hardcore blue states they're
going after Donald Trump it will be
would be interesting cuz it harkens back
a little bit again harkens back
to the South post-reconstruction when
you know some people don't realize there
were some jurisdictions where nobody
voted Republican because that wasn't an
option on the ballot so III think it's
unconstitutional says it's a short
answer I haven't I haven't studied this
I've just sort of followed it out of the
corner of my eye I think it's
unconstitutional under the term limits
decision because there were states that
tried to create term limits on members
of Congress through this same mechanism
and the the Court struck that struck
these down and said just what you said
you can't you can't apply additional
requirements beyond what's in the
Constitution so that's I that's my
instinct on that and yeah it certainly
would be first of all thank you so much
for what you're doing you talked about
the centralization of power and the
federal government but you didn't talk
and I'm wondering what your thoughts are
on the concentration of power not just
in the federal government but in the
office of the presidency because if you
have national voter standards Congress
cannot possibly deal with all of the
details of election law in a bill and so
what in effect this would require is for
some federal agency to promulgate
regulations which under current
constitutional law don't have to be
approved by anybody and the president of
course appoints because of the
appointments clause these individuals
would have to be appointed by the
President and even if it was a
bipartisan Commission they could be
removed by the president for cause so
what you really the argument is and I'm
interested in your action you're really
giving the president United States and
his appointees or her appointees the
power to dictate the election process
all over the country for their own
reelection and rule number one to
prevent tyranny is done
give the chief executive the ability to
control the rules for their own election
is that a valid argument here in this
case do you think oh yeah okay
sure thing I mean that no that that is
that is absolutely correct and something
I often times point out to state state
legislators and again no reason why
there have been I mean I I just want to
emphasize it's not there's a partisan
angle to this obviously after 2016 but
but there there have been many Democrats
state legislators who have recognized
exactly that point right we don't want
presidential appointees in charge of
presidential elections that's Banana
Republic stuff right and and obviously
in the present climate that you know
that has particular reason to frighten
people on a certain side and and you
know everybody should be concerned about
know that that's I mean that's exactly
right for all kinds of reasons anything
like national popular vote would have
grand eyes the federal government no I
just I'd be happy to stick around and
chat with folks during the reception I'm
so thankful to Hillsdale College and
Matt Spaulding for for entertaining me
and and for all of you listening to to
all of this I the the Sabre states
project was created particularly to
track this national popular vote effort
at the state level and it also make the
case more broadly for federalism
particularly in elections and so I mean
I encourage you to and go to save our
state's comm or find us on Facebook we
try to push out a lot of information
about what's going on in the states
particularly because that's where that's
where all this is happening and and this
is a wonderful issue for the following
reason most state legislators have never
really thought about the electoral
college
so I mean myself other people who work
on this issue I mean you can go and sit
down with a legislator who has sponsored
the bill to get rid of it to go for a
national popular vote and oftentimes
find that they're genuinely curious
about the issue walk them through all of
these arguments that I've laid out today
and I've had numerous legislators say oh
take my name off this bill I now
understand this is a bad idea
so it this really is an area where
individual citizens have made a
tremendous
friends in in the defense of the
electoral college and I hope you'll
you'll join me in doing that thank you
all so much
[Applause]